>>> FIRST NEW ON CNN, A NEW
WITNESS FOR THE JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE.
CNN HAS LEARNED THAT FORMER
TRUMP NATIONAL SECURITY OFFICIAL
MATTHEW POTTINGER WILL TESTIFY
PUBLICLY AT THE NUMBER PUBLIC
HEARING IN PRIME TIME ON
THURSDAY.
POTTINGER RESIGNED IN THE
IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF THE
JANUARY 6th ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL.
HE WILL APPEAR ALONGSIDE FORMER
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE AIDE SARAH
MATTHEWS.
LET'S GO TO CNN'S SENIOR CRIME
AND JUSTICE REPORTER KATELYN
POLANTZ.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
LET'S START WITH MATTHEW
POTTINGER AND THESE DETAILS.
OBVIOUSLY HE WAS A PRETTY BIG
FIGURE IN THE WEST WING.
HE IS CONSIDERED TO BE HAVE
INFLUENCE IN THE WEST WING.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, POTTING WAS THE
DEPUTY NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER.
THAT'S A HIGH-RANKING POSITION,
HE'S ALONGSIDE ANOTHER PERSON
THE FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY SARAH MATTHEWS.
THEY'RE BOTH GOING TO BE LIVE
WITNESSES THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO CONFIRM FOR THURSDAY'S PRIME
TIERL HEARING.
ANDS YOU GUYS MENTIONED, IT'S
VERY NOTABLE.
BOTH OF THESE PEOPLE RESIGNED IN
THE IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF
JANUARY 6th.
THEY'RE NOT LIKELY TO BE VERY
FRIENDLY WITNESSES TO DONALD
TRUMP OR WHAT HAPPENED THERE ON
JANUARY 6th.
THEY WON'T BE MINCING WORDS, WE
DON'T EXPECT, WHENEVER THEY'RE
TESTIFYING.
BUT WE DO KNOW FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN
PREVIEWING THE HEARING OVER
RECENT DAYS THAT THEY WANT TO
TAKE US INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE,
MINUTE BY MINUTE.
187 MINUTES IN TOTAL, WHERE
DONALD TRUMP WAS DOING NOTHING.
THEY ARE GOING TO HOPE TO
ILLUSTRATE THAT.
NOT JUST WITH THESE LIVE
WITNESSES, BUT WITH WITNESSES
THAT THEY HAVE VIDEOTAPED.
WE'VE BEEN SEEING ALL OF THESE
DEPOSITIONS.
THERE ARE LOTS OF PEOPLE THAT
WERE IN THE WHITE HOUSE THAT DAY
THAT HAD SAT FOR TESTIMONY.
SO, ALL OF THAT IS GOING TO COME
TOGETHER IN THIS PRIME TIME
HEARING.
YOU KNOW, I WAS IN COURT
YESTERDAY FOR BANNON -- BANNON'S
TRIAL, JURY SELECTION.
AND I WAS SHOCKED TO SEE HOW
MANY POTENTIAL JURORS HAD REALLY
WATCHED CLOSELY TO CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON'S TESTIMONY.
KNEW HER NAME.
SHE, TOO, WAS NOT A HOUSEHOLD
NAME BEFORE SHE TESTIFIED.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE IF THE
COMMITTEE CAN RE-CREATE THAT
SORT OF FEELING WITH HUTCHINSON
WITH US NOW, GERALD GOLDMAN, HE
SERVED IN THE FIRST FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND RUNNING FOR
CONGRESS, DANIEL, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING WITH US.
MATTHEW POTTINGER, SARAH
MATTHEWS.
THESE ARE STAFFERS WHO WERE
KNOWN WITHIN THE HALLS OF THE
WEST WING, BUT NOT MAYBE TO THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY.
WHAT ROLE WILL THEY PLAY, DO YOU
THINK, THURSDAY NIGHT?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S VERY
INTERESTING THAT WE'RE NOW IN
THE EIGHTH HEARING.
AND WE'VE SEEN EXCERPTS FROM SO
MANY DEPOSITIONS.
BUT NOT FROM THESE TWO.
AND IT IS CLEAR THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN SAVING THESE
TWO WITNESSES FOR THE LAST
HEARING.
WHICH IS GOING TO DIVE INTO
TRUMP'S DERELICTION OF DUTY ON
THE DAY OF JANUARY 6th, WHEN HE
DID NOTHING TO STOP THE RIOTERS,
EVEN THOUGH HE WAS BEING
REQUESTED FROM ALL ANGLES, HIS
OWN TEAM, MIKE PENCE, CONGRESS,
THE REPUBLICAN CONGRESS PERSONS.
SO WE ARE GOING TO UNDERSTAND,
IN GREAT DETAIL, THROUGH THESE
TWO WITNESSES, WHAT TRUMP WAS
DOING THAT DAY.
AND ALSO, JOHN, AS YOU'LL
REMEMBER, THERE'S A SUSPICIOUS
GAP IN WHITE HOUSE RECORDS AS TO
WHAT CALLS WERE COMING IN AND
OUT FOR DONALD TRUMP.
FOR ABOUT SIX HOURS, THAT
CONVENIENTLY OVERLAPS WITH THE
RIOT.
SO I SUSPECT WE ARE GOING TO
LEARN MORE FROM THESE TWO
WITNESSES ABOUT WHO TRUMP WAS
SPEAKING TO.
AND WHAT HE WAS DOING THAT DAY.
>> AND SARAH MATTHEWS, DANIEL,
WAS A DEPUTY TO KAYLEIGH
McENANY, SHE OBVIOUSLY WAS IN
THE WEST WING, SAW WHAT HAPPENED
THAT DAY.
MATTHEW POTTINGER, JUST FOR
PEOPLE AT HOME WHO AREN'T
FAMILIAR WITH THIS NAME, HE'S
THE DEPUTY SECURITY ADVISER.
A HUGE JOB IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE RESIGNED IN PROTEST THAT DAY.
HE SAW WHAT HAD HAPPENED.
HE SAID IT WAS VERY CLEAR AFTER
TRUMP ATTACKED PENCE HE COULDN'T
WORK THERE ANYMORE.
HE WAS SOMEONE WHO HAD A
HIGH-RANKING POSITION, FELT THE
NEED TO RESIGN FOR WHAT
HAPPENED.
WHEN HE GOES BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE PUBLICLY, HE WAS
SOMEONE IN THE ROOM FOR A LOT OF
THE MEETINGS.
MAYBE NOT A LOT OF THE LEGAL
MEETINGS, WITH WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN EFFORTS TO OVERTURN
THE ELECTION.
BUT WHAT CAN HE REVEAL TO THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE INNERWORKS
OF THE WEST WING THAT DAY GIVEN,
OF COURSE, HIS KEY ROLE?
>> THE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL, AS YOU KNOW, KAITLAN,
IS THE BODY THAT OVERSEAS ALL OF
THE INTELLIGENCE AND LARGELY ALL
OF THE FOREIGN POLICY.
WITHIN THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND THE DEPUTY NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER IS THE ONE WHO --
EVERYTHING RUNS THROUGH THE
DEPUTY, GOING UP TO THE
PRESIDENT.
SO, I WOULD SUSPECT THAT
POTTINGER WOULD KNOW ABOUT WHAT
THE INTELLIGENCE WAS.
ABOUT THE EXPECTATIONS FOR WHAT
WAS GOING TO OCCUR ON JANUARY 6.
HE WILL BE ABLE TO SAY WHAT
DONALD TRUMP RECEIVED IN
BRIEFINGS FROM THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER ROBERT O'BRIEN
THAT POTTINGER PROBABLY WAS IN
THE ROOM FOR.
AND HE WILL BE ABLE TO SAY WHAT
COMMUNICATIONS OCCURRED WITHIN
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH WHICH WOULD
INCLUDE THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE OR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
OR ANY EVER THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, THE 17 AGENCIES, THAT
INCLUDE THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
SO, HE WILL HAVE A LOT OF
INFORMATION THAT DAY.
AND WHEN YOU PAIR IT WITH SARAH
MATTHEWS WHO WAS PROBABLY
PRESENT WITH DONALD TRUMP FOR
MUCH OF THE DAY, WE'RE LIKELY TO
GET A MUCH CLEARER PICTURE OF
WHAT DONALD TRUMP WAS DOING THAT
DAY.
I WOULD ADD, THAT THERE IS A
WITNESS THAT DONALD TRUMP
CALLED -- WE DON'T KNOW THE
IDENTITY OF THAT WITNESS, BUT IT
IS SOMEONE THAT LIZ CHENEY SAID
HAS NOT YET APPEARED.
AND IT IS SOMEONE WE UNDERSTAND
WHO WORKED IN THE WHITE HOUSE
WHO DONALD TRUMP DID NOT HAVE
SIGNIFICANT RELATIONSHIP WITH.
I WILL BE VERY INTERESTED TO
HEAR WHETHER ONE OF THESE
WITNESSES RECEIVED THAT CALL.
I WOULD SUSPECT THAT IS THE
CASE.
>> CNN HAS BEEN TOLD BY
REPORTING THAT THE STAFF -- A
SUPPORT STAFF MEMBER BEFORE.
BUT WE'LL SEE.
DANIEL GOLDMAN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR HELP IN
UNDERSTANDING ALL OF THIS.
>> THANKS, JOHN.
>> AT LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS
MATTHEW POTTINGER.
SOURCES ARE TELLING CNN THAT
MATTHEW POTTINGER IS A FORMER
TRUMP NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
OFFICIAL.
HE WOULD NOT TESTIFY PUBLICLY
ON THURSDAY'S PRIMETIME HEARING
ALONG FORMER TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
AIDE, SARAH MATTHEWS.
THIS IS WHY POTTINGER SAYS HE
LEFT THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
HERE IT IS.
>> ONE OF MY STAFF BROUGHT ME A
PRINT OUT OF A TWEET BY THE
PRESIDENT.
AND THE TWEET SAID SOMETHING TO
THE EFFECT OF, MIKE PENCE, THE
VICE PRESIDENT DIDN'T HAVE THE
COURAGE TO DO WHAT SHOULD'VE
BEEN DONE.
WE I READ THAT TWEET AND MADE A
DECISION AT THAT MOMENT TO
RESIGN.
THAT IS WHERE I KNEW THAT I WAS
LEAVING THAT DAY.
ONCE I HAD READ THAT TWEET.
>> SARAH MATTHEWS, ALSO
TESTIFIED THAT SHE THOUGHT
TRUMP WAS POURING GASOLINE ON
THE FIRE WITH THAT WHEAT.
THAT WAS DURING THE 187 MINUTES
THE COMMITTEE WILL BE FOCUSING
ON.
WHAT GAPS WOULD THESE WITNESSES,
DO YOU THINK IN YOUR ESTIMATION,
BE ABLE TO FEEL ABOUT THAT
CRITICAL TIME PERIOD WE?
THERE'S >> STILL NO STEPS, DON.
WHOSE FATHER NORMS INDICATORS
HERE.
THAT 24 TWEET.
THAT PROMPTED PONDERS
RESIGNATION.
I THINK THAT'S AN AWFUL LOT OF
TIME THAT NEEDS TO BE FILLED
IN.
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO GET A
COMPLETE PICTURE OF WHAT DONALD
TRUMP WAS DOING UNLESS MARK
MEADOWS WERE TO FLIP, FOR
EXAMPLE.
THAT SEEMS UNLIKELY.
BUT INVESTIGATOR, AS A
PROSECUTOR, YOU HAVE TO DO THE
BEST WITH WHAT YOU GOT.
I THINK BETWEEN THE TESTIMONY
OF CASSIDY HUTCHINSON WOULD
FILL IN SOME OF THOSE.
MICS SARAH MATTHEWS.
MATTHEW PALMER.
WE ARE GOING TO START TO SEE A
BETTER SENSE OF WHAT DONALD
TRUMP WAS DOING AND NOT DOING.
AND ALSO, WHAT WAS HIS REACTION
TO WHAT HE WAS WATCHING.
I THINK THE VAST MAJORITY
PEOPLE THIS COUNTRY WERE
HORRIFIED BY WHAT WE WERE
SEEING.
BUT WE HAVE SEEN SOME
INDICATIONS, FOR EXAMPLE,
STEPHANIE GRETCHEN SAID A FEW
MONTHS BACK ON A NEW DAY THAT
SHE SAW DONALD TRUMP WAS LETHAL
AT WHAT HE WAS WATCHING.
SO WE ARE WOULD HAVE TO FILL IN
THE BIKES.
WE ARE NOT NECESSARILY GOING TO
GET, I DON'T COMMITTEE KEEPS A
MINUTE BY BENNETT.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO LITERALLY
BE ABLE TO CHRISTMAS BY
BENNETT.
BUT I THINK THEY CAN DO QUITE A
BIT TOUGHER THAN THAT THREE
HOUR AND SEVEN MINUTE GAP.
>> --
JUST.
ONE OF THE THINGS I CERTAINLY
FEEL LIKE I'VE LEARNED IN THIS
HEARING IS JUST HOW IMPORTANT
THIS 2:24 TWEET WAS.
THINK ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING ON
AT THAT POINT.
THE CAPITAL IS UNDER ATTACK AT
THAT MOMENT.
THE ASSAULT HAS BEGUN.
AND WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT
DOING.
HE SAYS, HE ATTACKS MIKE PENCE.
AND WE HAVE SEEN VIDEO OF THE
RIOTERS READING THE TWEET OUT
LOUD.
AND SAYING, LOOK, THE PRESIDENT
IS WITH US.
THAT IS WHEN THE HANG MIKE
PENCE STARTS.
IT IS JUST SO IMPORTANT TO
LEARN THE CONTEXT OF WHY HE
TWEETED THAT STATEMENT AT THAT
TIME.
AND THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM,
MAYBE, WILL HAVE TO EXPLAIN
THAT A BIT AS WELL.
>> ANY PERSON, ANY BOSS, ANY
LEADER.
YOU SEE RIDERS GOING INTO THE
CAPITAL.
WITH TRUMP HAS ON.
RIGHT?
WHEN THE FIRST THING YOU DO IS
GET FROM THE CAMERA AND SAY
STOP IT.
THIS IS NOT WHAT WE ARE ABOUT.
>> 187 MINUTES.
THAT IS A LONG TIME.
IT SOUNDS SHORTER HAS HE JUST
SAID.
IT IS THREE HOURS AND SEVEN
MINUTES.
HE HAD A LONG TIME AND HE HAD
ACCESS TO CAMERAS.
>> YOU JUST GOT THE BRIEFING
ROOM?
JUST WALK OVER TO THE BRIEFING
ROOM.
AND SAY, LOOK, GUYS STOP IT.
THIS IS NOT WHAT AMERICA'S
ABOUT.
>> MAYBE THE REASON WHY BECAUSE
HE DIDN'T WANT THEM TO STOP.
THAT'S WHAT I'M.
THANK YOU FOR SAY WHAT WOULD
YOU EXPECT.
WHAT DID YOU EXPECT HIM TO DO?
>> I EXPECT HIM TO BE THE
PRESIDENT.
AND GO AND THEY STOP IT TO NOT
TAKE 187 MINUTES.